>> Jon: WELCOME BACK.
SO LAST WEEK AS WE WERE
WATCH ON THE SHOW, LAST WEEK
WE LEARNED THAT WHILE OUR
UNITED STATES SENATE WAS
UNABLE TO PASS EVEN THE MOST
BASIC GUN CONTROL MEASURES,
AUSTRALIA HAD A SUCCESSFUL
GUN CONTROL FOR ALMOST TWO
DECADE, JOHN OLIVER VISITED
THERE TO FIND OUT MORE IN
PART TWO OF OUR THREE PART
SERIES.
>> IN 1996 FOLLOWING A
MASSACRE, AUSTRALIA'S
CONSERVATIVE GOVERNMENT
ENFORCED A NATIONAL BUYBACK
OF SEMIAUTOMATIC WEAPONS.
WHILE ALSO HEAVILY
REGULATING THE PURCHASE AND
STORAGE OF OTHER FIREARMS.
THE RESULT WAS DRAMATICALLY
REDUCED LEVEL OF GUN
VIOLENCE.
SO WHY CAN'T WE DO THAT
HERE?
TO FIND OUT I SAT DOWN WITH
LONG TIME AID TO HARRY REID
JIM MANLY.
>> THE NRA IS STILL A VERY
POWERFUL FORCE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THEY HAVE FOUR MILLION
MEMBERS WHO ARE VERY, VERY
DETERMINED TO GET THEIR WAY.
>> AND HOW CAN A NATION OF
300 MILLION COMPETE WITH
THAT?
>> IT'S DIFFICULT TO
UNDERSTAND SOMETIME, ISN'T
IT BUT THE FACT OF THE MAT
CERTIFICATE THAT I'VE GOT TO
THINK LONG AND HARD BEFORE
YOU SUPPORT GUN CONTROL
LEGISLATION BECAUSE YOU ARE
TAKE ON THE NRA CAN BE
POLITICAL SUICIDE.
>> AND THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
IS WORKING TIRELESSLY TO
REDUCE THE RATE OF POLITICAL
SUICIDE AMONG ITS MEMBERS.
SURELY AUSTRALIAN
POLITICIANS WEREN'T STUPID
ENOUGH TO END THEIR
POLITICAL LIVES FOR GUN
CONTROL.
>> WELL, I DID.
>> WHAT?
>> I DID.
>> YOU DID WHAT?
>> I TOOK THE STAND.
I WAS PREPARED TO FACE THE
POLITICAL CONSEQUENCES, AND
WE DELIVERED GUN CONTROL.
>> MEETS ROB BOREBICH FORMER
PREMIER OF QUEENSLAND,
AUSTRALIA'S MOST
CONSERVATIVE STATE.
IN 1996 HE WAS INSTRUMENTAL
IN ENACTING GUN CONTROL,
KNOWING IT WOULD COST HIM
HIS POLITICAL CAREER IN THE
NEXT ELECTION.
>> WE PAID A HIGH POLITICAL
PRICE BUT WE DID THE RIGHT
THING.
LOOK, THERE ARE AUSTRALIANS
ALIVE TODAY BECAUSE WE TOOK
THAT ACTION.
I MEAN HOW MUCH SAY LIFE
WORTH?
>> BUT JIM MANLY KNOWS THAT
THE TRUE PUBLIC SERVANT HAS
NOR IMPORTANT CONCERNS.
>> WHAT MAKES A POLITICIAN
SUCCESSFUL?
>> GETTING RE-ELECTED BY HIS
OR HER CONSTITUENTS.
>> RIGHT, YEAH.
THAT IS HOW YOU JUDGE
SUCCESS.
>> OKAY, THAT-- WELL,
GETTING LEGISLATION DONE.
>> IS SECOND.
>> IS SECOND, YES.
>> THAT IS SECOND.
HOLLY [BLEEP], THAT IS
SECOND?
>> IF I COULD REWIND THIS
TAPE I WOULD SAY GETTING
LEGISLATION DONE AND GETTING
RE-ELECTED BY YOUR
CONSTITUENTS.
>> BUT SERIOUSLY YOU CAN'T
REMIND-- REWIND THE TAPE
LET'S GO WITH THE ANSWER YOU
GAVE.
>> IF YOU DON'T GET
RE-ELECTED, YOU KNOW, YOU
JUST ROADKILL IN THE
POLITICAL PROCESS AND YOU'RE
JUST ANOTHER LOSER.
>> TRAGICALLY NOT EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS THIS.
>> WHAT MAKES A POLITICIAN
SUCCESSFUL?
GO.
>> MAKING SOCIETY A BETTER
PLACE.
>> NO, NO, NO, ROB, NO.
LOOK, WE CAN-- WE CAN
ACTUALLY REWIND THE TAPE.
ARE WE ROLLING?
WHAT MAKES A POLITICIAN
SUCCESSFUL.
>> YOUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
GOVERN IN THE BEST INTERESTS
OF THE PEOPLE THAT YOU
SERVE.
>> LOOK, ROB, I'M GOING OUT
ON A LIMB HERE.
I ALREADY TOLD SOMEONE ELSE
I CAN'T DO THIS WHEN I CAN.
>> I HOPE YOU HAVE A LOT OF
TAPE.
>> TRUE SUCCESS IS A
LIFELONG POLITICIAN LIKE
HARRY REID WHOSE WATERED
DOWN GUN LEGISLATION WAS
CAREFULLY DESIGNED TO
PROTECT THOSE WHO NEEDED IT
MOST.
>> HE HAS A RESPONSIBILITY
AS THE DEMOCRATIC LEADER TO
PROTECT THE CAUCUS.
>> THE CAUCUS NEEDS TO BE
PROTECTED, THE CAUCUS DOES.
>> THEY NEED TO BE PROTECTED
POLITICALLY.
>> HOW MANY POLITICAL
CAREERS HAVE BEEN TRAGICALLY
ENDED BY GUN CONTROL.
>> WE'VE LOST SOME GOOD
FOLKS OVER THE YEARS BECAUSE
OF THEIR VIEWS.
>> RIGHT.
YOU HAVE A PERFECTLY HEALTHY
POLITICAL CAREER AND THEN
BANG.
>> JUST LIKE THAT.
>> WHICH MEANS FORMER
AUSTRALIA PRIME MINISTER
JOHN HOWARD HAS BLOOD ON HIS
HANDS.
>> DOW EVER THINK ABOUT THE
INNOCENT VICTIMS OF YOUR GUN
CONTROL.
>> THERE WERE NO INNOCENT
VICTIMS OF MY-- THERE WERE
NO VICTIMS AT ALL.
THERE IS THE PHOTOGRAPH OF
ROB, HE WAS INCREDIBLY
COURAGEOUS SUPPORTING OUR
LAWS.
>> BUT POLITICALLY HE IS
DEAD, BANG, JUST LIKE THAT.
>> WE LOST AN ELECTION AS WE
ALL DO AT SOME POINT.
>> BUT HOWARD IS NOT ALONE.
HIS DEPUTY PRIME MINISTER
TIM FISHER ALSO REFUSES TO
ACCEPT RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THESE CAREER MASSACRES.
>> OH, YOU DON'T LOOK AT
THESE FACES AND FEEL GUILT?
>> WELL, THEY ARE ALIVE.
AND --
>> THEY'RE DEAD, THEY'RE
POLITICALLY DEAD.
>> I HOPE THAT THOSE WHO
TOTALLY VETO ANY MOVE TO
BRING SENSIBLE, SEMI AUCTION
AND AUCTION WEAPON CONTROL
TO THE SUBURBS OF AMERICA
ARE ALSO POLITICALLY DEAD
BUT PHYSICALLY ALIVE.
>> NOT IN I COULD HELP IT.
NEVER AGAIN WILL A POLITICAL
CAREER END IN A SENSELESS
ACT OF MEANINGFUL
LEGISLATION.
>> THE VERDICT IS JUST ALL
OF THESE, ALL OF THEM ARE
DEAD, POLITICALLY NOT
PHYSICALLY, PHYSICALLY THEY
ARE PROBABLY SAFER.
>> IT IS VERY DARK.
>> I MEAN AGAIN, JUST TO
REITERATE PHYSICALLY THEY
ARE ABSOLUTELY FINE BUT IT
MAKES YOU THINK.
>> UNFORTUNATELY, WHAT
SPENDING TIME WITH
POLITICALLY DEAD AUSTRALIA
POLITICIANS MADE ME THINK
ABOUT WAS HOW HORRIBLY WRONG
WE HAVE IT IN AMERICA.
>> THANKS FOR SPEAK WITH ME
ROB.
>> PLEASURE.
>> ARE YOU A GREAT HUMAN
BEING.
>> THANK YOU.
>> IT'S JUST BY ALL AMERICAN
STANDARDS, YOU ARE A [BLEEP]
POLITICIAN.
AND THE FACT THAT THAT IS
TRUE IS WHY I AM NOW GOING
TO WALK INTO THE [BLEEP]
OCEAN.
>> IN AMERICA WE'RE TOLD GUN
CONTROL IS NOT POSSIBLE.
BUT IN AUSTRALIA, THEY HAVE
SHOWN IT IS.
PROVIDING A FANTASTIC LESSON
FOR AMERICA TO IGNORE.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Jon: JOHN OLVER, WE'LL BE